[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I don't know about you but I can't stop
thinking about Red Dead Redemption too
as it sits in between both Red Dead
Revolver and Red Dead Redemption I think
there's a good chance that a quite a few
cameos will be made in Red Dead
Redemption too we already know about
John Marston and Abigail and of course
the van der Linde gang were a member of
you know Dutch Xavier bill Williamson
and even uncle looks like a member of
the outlaw community but I was thinking
what about other characters that could
be in Red Dead Redemption to knowing
Rockstar they won't be able to resist
cameos from the Red Dead Saga in small
glimpses our entire side-quests
so here's nine characters I expect to
see in Redemption - before we crack on
if you haven't played Red Dead Revolver
or Red Dead Redemption or maybe the
story is a little hazy
check out this breakdown of the story so
far because this will include spoilers
for those games let's start with the
antagonist of Red Dead Redemption
Edgar Ross we all remember his demise so
damned satisfying and we all remember
what a ruthless son of a boo focused
individual he was operating for the
Bureau of Investigation which later
became the FBI before I shoot you myself
let me just point out the audience your
wife
Red Dead Redemption - starts out 12
years before we first met John Marston
in Blackwater and more importantly nine
years before the Bureau of Investigation
was formed in this time period
Ross would be around 38 years old and we
could see him climb the ranks of Lauryn
daughter whether that's via the US
Marshals the army or even the Blackwater
Police Department in Red Dead Redemption
Edgar Ross was focused on the future
modernization he didn't write horseback
he took a vehicle he even preferred
automatic weapons when given the choice
Ross represented the downfall of outlaws
but his tactics showed cunning and the
destructive force of manipulation Edgar
Ross 12 years younger could very well
show up in Red Dead Redemption - and I
thought about you but I'm gonna shoot
him and cause a time paradox it'll be
worth it
hello John John Marston
do I know you I hope so I seem to know
you here's one which gives me the chills
the strange man the mysterious man
during John's quest for redemption
this fellow popped up regularly and
appears to know everything about John's
history things we don't even know yet
the third time we met this mysterious
strange man he notes this is a fine spot
hey there's a beautiful spot sure what
are you doing here
my accounts it seems pointless at the
time but this exact spot ends up being
John's burial site scary it gets weirder
John attempts to kill him during the
cutscene and he's immortal tell me your
name or I won't be responsible for my
actions oh but you will damn you
yes many have he appears in photos and
pictures around the world - and leaves
us with more questions than answers
people believe he's God he Satan he's
the grim reaper he has to pop up in Red
Dead Redemption - right Oh as an extra
point to this he also makes this comment
then why would you remember me friend
you've forgotten far more important
people than me could this explain away
why we never heard about Arthur Morgan
in Red Dead Redemption 1
don't mention it old man you kill
peasants you become a peasant down in
Mexico we met London Ricketts a
seemingly retired old man but look a
little closer and we see a man with a
wealth of knowledge about the Old West
and how did he acquire this knowledge he
was the fastest gun in the West and thus
had fame and fortune in his life when we
meet him in Mexico London is living out
his retirement in tuberosa protecting
the village from constant unlawful
individuals looking into his past we
know that in 1899 the Year Red Dead
Redemption 2 begins London was involved
in the Blackwater massacre he is the
great thing about this atrocious event
nobody in 1911 knew how or why it
started some say 37 men died that day
could we see what happened firsthand
through the eyes of Arthur Morgan I'm
betting we do sadly London's voice actor
passed away shortly after the release of
the first red
rest in peace mr. Hagen I do hope if
London reappears that he is given an
epic gunfight in your honor sir
excuse me sir I seem to have found
myself in a most unfortunate situation
if you would be kind enough to help me
you ain't my problem
during the campfire scenes it's possible
to hear about characters in Red Dead
Revolver Jack Swift is one of them back
in the 1880s Jack fled England a bank
robber and sharpshooter and crossed the
globe to America in order to find fame
and glory he first joined a circus to
demonstrate his skills with jewelry
vulvas in hand by the way his robbers
are known as the showstoppers pretty
damn cool in Red Dead Revolver jack is
saved from execution by Red Hollow and
the two fight side by side they meet
again in the Battle Royale
and finally go after the governor
together I'll keep these devils at bay
you see where that passage leads Jack
saves Reds life by staying to fight and
this presumed dead but Chuck's fate was
never confirmed when other characters
were asked about his actions
Jack they look sad solemn as if he had
died could Jack Swift appear in Red Dead
Redemption - I do think there'll be a
little Easter egg in his honor okay
marshals of the law when the shooting
starts take that as your cue to start
awarding each other medals huh one of
the most bombastic people we met in Red
Dead Redemption was nigel west dickens
we first saw him on the roadside he'd
been shot and was poetically waiting for
his death
come on mister come on Martin save his
life that day and the two began to work
together Nigel to put it bluntly is a
swindler using his gift as a salesman to
con people into buying his elixir John
played along to great effect you sir
come up here step right up a newspaper
found in the game stated a woman with
one leg grew back her limb from Nigel's
elixir and a man on his deathbed got up
and went to the nearest brothel with a
vigor of a fourteen-year-old boy Nigel's
mouth has seen him running to the lure a
few times but luckily John has been
around to see him freed because he's a
harmless old fraud can a man that built
this country nigel west dickens was a
large part of Red Dead Redemption and
will likely appear in the second game
hopefully as charismatic as ever
[Music]
one of Nigel's closest affiliates is the
monstrosity of a man Seth briars
Seth is first seen raiding graves
looking for precious materials he
certainly comes across like Gollum from
Lord of the Rings
his obsession with treasure causes him
to lose his family and his hygiene and
arguably his sanity too he had a
treasure hunting partner in red dead
named Moses forth the two of them could
pop up in Red Dead Redemption 2 as their
desire to become wealthy rips apart
their family and their friendship in
1914 a newspaper reveals that Seth
hauled a huge sack of valuable jewels
into Blackwater he returned to his
family and reopened his business oh that
noise a quick note about another
bit-part character in red Dead's first
act Irish these horses look fresher if
you haven't figured out already
he's an Irish immigrant playing up the
most offensive stereotype you can
imagine he's an alcoholic
with a thick accent cowardly behavior
and lately too he's even said to have
killed himself accidentally in 1911
after his weapon misfired poor guy I
personally think he has more to offer
than this small part in red dead and
judging by the first time we meet him
your little patty yeah
got it all wrong wish all wrong it was
French I promise he said he was going to
rip you off
no he's ripping me off yes he won't talk
in here he has a cast of crazy
characters alongside him could they make
it into Red Dead Redemption - I've seen
strongmen wither and die under that
unforgiving Sun that whole herds cow
takes sick and died but I've never once
doubted my life here no sir the
McFarland ranch was the place John
stayed during his recovery after he was
shot by Bill's men for whilst here we
got to know Bonnie McFarlane and her
daddy drew performing day-to-day chores
as well as preventing Bonnie from being
hanged you know every everyday stuff
what's interesting about the McFarland
is the six brothers Bonnie has five of
which are dead by 1911 when John first
arrives if you're wondering about the
last brother he moved to New York in
1899 when Red Dead Redemption too begins
we may see the full mcfarland family and
finally find out what happened to all
her brothers my bet is at least one of
them died in the Blackwater massacre we
talked about with London Ricketts and
remember the Year Red Dead Redemption
too begins is the year of that infamous
gunfight who shall we pick for number
nine Annie Stokes Marshall Johnson may
be sheriff Bartlett there are so many
great characters who could return as
major characters or at least
little tiny easter eggs without a doubt
we have to finish with red Harlow the
star of Red Dead Revolver Red's been
through a lot watching his parents
killed in cold blood having his hand
severely burned during his retaliation
and taking on the entire Mexican army
losing his cousin in the process red
Harlow is spoken of in Red Dead
Redemption and is seen as a legend of
the Old West
due to his unwavering devotion to doing
the right thing regardless of
consequences his last act in revolver
sees him avenge his parents but this act
will see him hanged forcing him to live
his final days as an outlaw on the run
what ever happened to dread Harlow I'm
dying to know what else he achieved in
the final days of the Old West I'll
never forget the reward he was offered
and his final words in red
[Music]
it never was about the money
come on that's damn poetic well said
read so there we have it nine possible
returning characters for Red Dead
Redemption - who do you think will see
from previous Red Dead titles I think
the least we'll get our Easter eggs -
those nine characters and families we've
just looked at what do you reckon I hope
you enjoyed right that redemption - I'm
Arden from PlayStation granade it's been
a bloody pleasure I'll see you next time
you
[Music]